[Musique]
je vous dis ce soir on va faire un grand
le musical pendant vingt-cinq est de
minutes oui ça existe ça va on après on
apprend le français tous les jours le
français est une langue bien dit évolué
vivent et évoluent comme la vie comme
elle est vivante contrairement à vous ok
si c'est cette équipe qui gagne ouais
tout le public gagnera un magnifique
cadeau si c'est cette équipe où le
public
on va jouer pour avoir pascal dans son
équipe joue également un vous avez à
buzzer est-ce qu'on peut installer les
buzzer non merci
très bien vous levez la main pour jouer
en équipe pascal va faire des chansons
de lui d'accord les chéris celui ceux
qui auront marqué le plus de points euro
pascal dans leur équipe si on donne
l'interprète ça marche
ouais mais là ils essuient des mois vous
savez que je trouve cette bonne très
bonne merci oui vous êtes magnifique
baie naïve et vous êtes comme ça vous
vous êtes sur l'autoroute du succès va
falloir à un moment vous arrêtez payer
le péage
pascal l'artiste le rideau s'ouvre taton
piano taton instrumentale et ben tu
fermes ta gueule
[Rires]
tu fais quoi tu veux je passais des
intros c'est ça ou je chante alors je
vais les intros et après on se fait un
petit cubano bar tu vois journée en
direct
mais on en tire est d'ailleurs nommée
chaud on est en délire vous essayez de
trouver vous levez la main ce brésil là
millésime c'était millésime simon ma
plus belle année
pour ce l'honneur en prime
que tu jour de l'est
je suis
jamais
c'est ça être père
sur tes coups tout son poids et sa
destinée après pascal c'est sûr dé quoi
sur les dix sur des coteaux nos potes et
la barre mais c'est bon tu vas pas tout
la ferme et non mais je kiffe tâche sur
des coteaux en compte les vallons
amoureux un rayon de soleil c'est sur
nous deux j'adore c'est que je connais
par coeur
c'est gentil mais aussi rim merci obispo
à l'oignon vatanen a travaillé ensemble
chez de la mondaine oliva et artois pour
vous deuxième titre c'est parti on y va
cette prime certes rien préparé tous ces
mets et tu crois que près de pêche aux
quelque chose moi ok bouche à bouche ne
bouge pas on est en direct chez nous
non
non il n'ya qu'à saint joseph jugé
pakistanais mais si mais si
lui c est ce que celui-ci s'est démarqué
dans les livres
[Applaudissements]
ces deux villes jouent le temps c'est de
l'amour marqué dans les livres
le plus important à vivre et c'est vivre
au jour le jour
le sens de l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les soirs comme ça où tout s'écroule
tout nous faut savoir pourquoi toujours
regarder devant se voir sans jamais ses
bras ça pourrait être un bon dvd sont
aussi tombés et t'as vu comment je suis
fan tu nous es bat et là pour sa baie
merci mon pascal talla bois et hoppop
emerson tuer et passé toile à travers
deux pakistanais isi qui mène au procès
et nous verrons bien dans son importance
en contactant salon privé c'est pour moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais perdre et je vais faire pu dire
j'avais fait un peu difficile à faire un
peu salace et c'est jouer avec le
couplet ou que leur faim alors et alors
j'adore
est ce qu'on peut faire on peut se faire
à lens mais tu peux me la faire des gens
en mi bémol
ok tu vas et tu me fais surtout je suis
tombé pour
tu dis tout gelé d'yeux que pour elle
tue tout la maison main
tout comme m
elle loue île aux oiseaux
[Musique]
une aux oiseaux
aux intentions de vendre tous les soirs
je pourrais faire un truc comme ça si tu
as d'autres chroniques comme ça écoute
tu sais quoi si t'es pas cher tu peux
venir tous les soirs franchement verotel
bienvenue qui vient ici tu postes les
bestiaux c'est quoi mon chéri tu veux
j'en fasse une difficile on est on est
commandes
alors là on continuer c'est pas non plus
des foudres de guerre le chili il ya
2.166 mon pascal il t'en fais encore
devant pascal à les écoutent oui si tu
veux vraiment l'amour thème le piano en
fait un tueur repart avec un bon je vais
faire une chanson que j'ai fait pour
quelqu'un d'autre d'accord
non je vais choisir une autre attente
attente en ont mais gnl disent avoir
aimé mais sa voix
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
mais sans attirer apprendre à sourire
rien que pour le geste son couloir et
apprend rabin et s'en aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au regard des six bourgeois les sur ces
8 on est en direct et je fais un truc
personne n'a jamais fait on est à 2
partout ce sera le dernier titre mais
juste avant regardez je vais faire ce
que jamais aucun homme là est déjà fait
je vais essayer de voler on est à y
regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est joli tard l opération le 10 mars
au stade houphouet encodeur pascal oui
moi je vais alors pour départager
alors je me sens jeune est difficile non
non fenua qui fait loin qui voit l'un
pour toi for me
fenech
cette provision
[Applaudissements]
ceci a
ce soit nous le
chemin pour que
qu'on soit seul et new trabi de voler
ça
ce soit
à nous de nous
voix
je fais
qu'on aura partagé la vie de mes hommes
[Applaudissements]
oh
saturday 10 secondes pascal jusqu'en
amont
[Applaudissements]